hoping for answers while Beth who has
autism remains locked in what her father
describes as a cell we joined him at the
family home to listen to what the health
secretary had to say about failures in
her care I apologized to Jeremy and
frankly to Bethany for the things that
have gone wrong in her care the current
plan is to for her to be moved to a more
appropriate setting before Christmas I
very much hope that will happen of
course that requires a space to become
available and there are some other there
are some other had people with also very
very serious conditions that and complex
cases that that's currently in the
setting that we that the NHS thinks is
most appropriate for Bethany's I welcome
Matt apologizing I welcome him
recognising there is a need to sort out
my daughter's provision and that doing
that by Christmas would be absolutely
brilliant for the whole family but as I
say it's another promise it's another
plan it's another mention of yet more
reviews because matters are not
announced this on television I'm quite
sure that Bethany will be aware and
Bethany will hang on every word that
Matt and Rob has said so it hope he has
something obviously are you confident
that she does know this to me this is
yet more promises Beth was sectioned
under the Mental Health Act when she was
15 for the last three years she's been
kept in a room with minimum contacts and
meals slid to her on a tray across the
floor but Jeremy told us that in recent
weeks there have been improvements since
Skye has broadcast my daughter's story
the hospital have had a member of staff
go in from a team from the NHS I'm
really pleased to be able to say that
since the first couple of hours of them
working with Beth Beth has been outside
of the cell regularly she's been outside
playing football playing netball
badminton she's been doing drama with a
care staff outside Bella last time we
spoke better that's for the dolls
because she'd lonely she was lonely
support for Beth arrives daily gifts and
cards that they will share together hope
now is that the perfect gift the right
care for Beth will arrive in time for
Christmas dan whited Sky News in
Birmingham